L'Europe n'est plus 1 champion industriel,
ce n'est plus 1 champion
économique non plus, coincé entre des blocs
américains et chinois.
Il nous reste donc que l'Europe doit être 1 champion
écologique, le modèle que
tous les continents peuvent prendre en
exemple pour avancer au plus vite vers la
neutralité carbone mondiale
en deux-mille-cinquante.
C'est la seule façon dont l'Europe peut
retrouver sa puissance
et son indépendance,
indépendance énergétique vis-à-vis de la Russie,
indépendance idéologique vis-à-vis des États-Unis,
indépendance commerciale vis-à-vis de la Chine
et cetera et cetera et cetera.
C'est le seul moyen de défendre 1 modèle politique
démocratique et d'en faire 1 réussite.
L'écologie n'est plus 1 à côté sympa à avoir.
C'est la seule voie de développement pour 1 Europe
qui perd en poids diplomatique,
économique et idéologique.
J'en ai discuté avec Rafael gluxman
et il est d'accord avec moi et vous.